[Music]
in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us most of us would say that
about a bowl of hot soup especially when
you're not feeling well and chicken soup
has been a popular cold remedy for
generations John Blackstone met an
arizona couple who bring the comforts of
home to sick college students one bowl
at a time these days college students
can order food on demand from just about
anywhere but this isn't your average
meal delivery service so how many are we
delivering today for more than a decade
Rabbi Shmuel tech tel and his wife Hana
have brought bowls of homemade chicken
soup to Arizona State University
students who are feeling under the
weather what is the magic of chicken
soup it's warm it's homey it makes you
feel better and it's not just the
chicken soup is the fact that somebody
threw up to come and give it to you
that's the fact that someone cares I
think chicken soup show is carrying that
love the couple who runs Habad house a
Jewish student center near campus says
their soup program started organically
but is now growing quickly a little
matzo ball soup there's a long way
chicken soup doesn't only cure Jewish
students right right absolutely we don't
ask you what religion you are you're not
feeling well you need chicken soup we
are there with chicken soup any ASU
student or their parents can place an
order for soup delivery over the phone
or through an online portal at no charge
the tech tells deliver about 15 bowls
every week our goal right now is to make
sixty four months of 64 matzo balls and
while many Jewish students may be
familiar with the traditional matzo ball
chicken soup others myself included
we're trying it for the first time okay
you heard a chicken soup before uh-huh
you're not Jewish no you hadn't had
matzo ball soup right and and I was just
like might as well try it I'm for new
things
Kyle kradic's mother ordered the soup
for him a few weeks ago describe the
taste to me it tastes like chicken
noodle
soup but then the matzo ball it's just
like overwhelmingly amazing I would say
Marlene wit our who lives near Los
Angeles ordered a bowl for her daughter
Hannah when she got sick last year it's
kind of scary when you think about your
kid you can't get to your kid but just
to have this one small thing that Habad
can do for the kids it gives me as a mom
living all these miles away some peace
of mind how quickly did it cure you
immediately Hannah is now the president
of the Habad Board and stores extra
Chicken Soup in her own freezer to
deliver to other students in need
because somebody cares about you and
it's really a beautiful thing that when
I'm so far from home somebody is still
here to make me chicken soup and to give
it to me and I'm sick like my mom did
chicken soup for you it's just seeing
the smile and a student's face that
makes it all worth it we hope that they
will feel that they received some good
and in turn they will pay it forward the
more goodness we can have going on I
mean our world would be so much of a
better space if we can you know change
the world with one bowl at a time that
would be really good I can taste the
love okay good for CBS this morning John
Blackstone Tempe Arizona I agree with
that what you can do with just a bowl of
soup making someone feel better sharing
kindness and wishing them well can I say
matzo ball soup is multi-denominational
right everyone everyone can eat it yeah
everyone loves it's comfort food that I
want right now actually with a bowl we
have a few options in New York for our
10:00 a.m. live